J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE : So we're
going to finish up talking about
aromaticity, talking then about
reactions, as well as
molecules that are unusually
stable.
That is, transition states that
are stabilized, that's
Diels-Alder reactions which are
cycloadditions, and also
other pericyclic reactions like
electrocyclic reactions.
Then we'll go on to
spectroscopy.
OK, so we're generalizing the
concept of aromaticity.
We saw last time that Hueckel
thought there would be unusual
stability when you add 4n+2 pi
electrons in a ring
that is, when you have an odd
number of electron pairs,
because every odd numbered
orbital goes down in energy
when you form a ring.
So if there's an odd number in
total, they're more
going down that up.
And then we'll go on to see as I
said about transition-state
aromaticity.
So first just one slides that
will be on the exam on Monday,
it's fair game anyhow, which is
some things that are not
benzenoid, but are still
aromatic.
Like cyclopentadiene, of course,
is a ring, but it's
not a ring of conjugated p
orbitals because there's one
intervening one, so the terminal
p orbitals of the
diene don't interact, don't
overlap with one another.
But if you pull off the protons
with a
base, then they interact.
So now you have five electrons--
this anion in the pi system--
and it's unusually stable.
You could pull off that hydrogen
from
a carbon with hydroxide.
The pKa of this compound is 15.
It's more acidic then water is.
It's better to pull a hydrogen
off that carbon then to pull a
hydrogen off oxygen.
Now what's the normal pKa for
pulling a
hydrogen off carbon?
Do you remember?
STUDENT: About 50?
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: It is about 50.
PROFESSOR: It's about 50.
Of course, this is allylic.
And in fact it's doubly allylic,
so you might
say that helps out.
No doubt it does help out.
But notice that it has 6 pi
electrons, same as benzene,
and we would expect on the basis
of our theory for it to
be unusually stable.
But if it's just that it's
allylic. Think about doing the
same thing with the 7-membered
ring.
If you pulled the hydrogen off
the CH2 here of a
7-membered ring, you get this
anion. Which would be
stabilized by that resonance
structure, that one, that one,
that one, that one, that one--
an enormous number of
resonance structures, but the
pKa is 39.
It's 10^24 less acidic than the
one on the 5-membered
ring-- even though you can draw
many fewer-- only five
resonance structures in that
case.
So it's not a question of
resonance structures.
It's a question of how many
electron pairs
there are in that ring.
And if it's an odd number it's
stable, and if it's an even
number of pairs, then it's not
stable.
So that one has 8 pi electrons--
4n.
It's antiaromatic instead of
being aromatic.
Another interesting analogue is
cyclopropene.
So here's a case of cyclopropene
reacting with an
unusually stable cation,
triphenylmethyl cation.
Notice that that cation is
triply benzylic.
There are three benzene rings
that helps stabilize the
positive charge
or to speak more accurately,
who's electrons are stabilize
by the vacant orbital on carbon.
Still, it's exothermic to
transfer the hydride--
notice it's a hydride not a
proton pulling off H minus
this onto the phenyl-CH3
[correction: Phenyl3CH]
to generate this cyclic
conjugated cation.
So that one is even more stable
then the unusually
stable triply benzylic one.
Now what's the accounting of
that one?
The accounting of pi electrons?
Ruoyi, can you tell me how many
pi electrons in a ring of
that cation?
Is it going to conform to 4n+2?
PROFESSOR: OK, we had a double
bond, that's two electrons and
what do we get from that center
when we pull off H
minus in the p orbital?
STUDENT: Zero.
PROFESSOR: So, how many do we
have?
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two.
Is that 4n+2, where n is an
integer?
STUDENT: n is zero.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's when n is
zero.
So that one you expect to be
unusually stable.
It's just got the one pair that
goes down in energy when
you form a ring.
Two pi electrons is 4n+2.
And notice that now if you go to
C7, here we went in the
anion to C7H8, pardon me, C7H7
anion.
Here to C7H7 cation, if we do
the same trick with that,
react this hydrocarbon with that
triphenylmethyl cation.
And that is also the same.
That's also downhill.
It's favorable to make this.
Does that conform to 4n+2?
What do you say, Rahul?
How many pi electrons in C7 H7
plus?
STUDENT: Six.
PROFESSOR: Six.
4n+2, same as benzene.
So here are some really weird
compounds, that you wouldn't
expect to be so unusually
stable, that are because it's a
generalization of the idea of
aromaticity.
But it applies not only to
ground states but also to
transition states. When you get
a ring that has a conjugation
among a bunch of orbitals where
the number of
electronics is 4n+2.
So in this case the transition
states are aromatic, even
though the starting material and
the
products are not aromatic.
What that means is that there's
special stability only
in the transition state, and
therefore the reactions will
be unusually easy.
So let's see if we have some
example of that.
We'll look at cycloadditons, in
particular, that
Diels-Alder reaction and also an
electrocyclic reactions.
We'll start with the
cycloadditions.
So that Diels-Alder reaction was
the subject of a Nobel
prize, surprisingly enough to
Diels and Alder.
It involved a diene reacting
with an alkene.
So an ene and a diene and they
react with one another was
three pairs of electrons
shifting to form a ring.
So it has four sigma electrons
that are involved in this, and
2 pi electrons in the product.
In the starting material, it's 4
pi
electrons and 2 pi electrons.
It's six electrons, three pairs,
that are being involved.
And we can write curbed arrows
like that, but we might want
to think about it a little more
carefully.
Suppose we just draw the two
approaching one another, HOMO
to LUMO like that.
Now there are two problems here.
One is that we've got the LUMO
drawn upside down.
In fact, there are three
problems. That we can just
write the signs the other way,
that's no problem.
Another problem is that the
hydrogens which we haven't
shown, the sigma hydrogens are
going to be running into one
another when we do that.
And there's also another
problem.
Somehow, pi electrons have to
become sigma
electrons here and here.
It has to be an end on, not a pi
interaction
in order to do that.
How can we get around these
problems?
Yes.
STUDENT: Rotate the ene.
PROFESSOR: OK, we can rotate the
ene 180 degrees.
That'll make the signs correct.
How do we get around the other
problems, let's say the
hydrogens running into one
another?
STUDENT: 90 degrees.
PROFESSOR: If we rotated it at
90 degrees that's true, but
you don't get the best overlap
that way for
forming a new bond.
Anybody else got an idea?
Brandon?
STUDENT: Can we just move it
under?
PROFESSOR: Put it under.
So make the approach where the
p is parallel to the direction
of the p axes like.
Now we got around all those
problems. So we can form this
new-- but notice the transition
state is folded
because of this, because they're
not coming
together in a plane.
So to see the product then we
have to unfold it.
We have to grab that bottom
black line and pull
it up into the plane.
So the product is then going to
look like that, once we
flatten it.
You can see the new bonds that
will form.
Now let's think a little bit
about what we would predict in
connection with stereochemistry
in this.
Suppose the starting alkene were
of a Z configuration.
Suppose it had two methyl groups
on it.
Then if you form those two bonds
at once, they'll still
be cis here, and they'll be
cis in the
product in methyl groups.
How about the diene?
Suppose, the diene had the E,
Z configuration, so methyl
that's cis here and
trans here.
Then if we look at the
transition state, it'll be
still cis here and trans here.
And if we flattened that out,
where will the methyls be in
the product?
How about there's going to be a
methyl here on that carbon,
is it going to be pointing
toward you or away when you
flatten the ring out?
If this is the way it is in the
transition state, try to
think of a mechanically, we
break this bond.
Is that going to be when we pull
this up and flatten it
out-- is that methyl going to be
coming up toward us or back
into the board?
This is a kind of mechanical
thinking that maybe-- we used
to require people to buy models,
you've seen those. And that
probably helped with this
mechanical perception.
How many think when you flatten,
and when you pull this
up the methyl there is going to
be pointing towards you?
How many think it's going to be
pointing away?
That's reassuring that the vast
majority
are right in this.
It's coming toward you.
So you can look at this in the
privacy of your room maybe use
toothpicks and grapes or
something to make a model and
see how it twists like that.
Now, how about this one when you
fold this up?
What's it going to be at the
bottom carbon?
How many think it's going to be
pointing toward you?
Have the courage of your
conviction.
How many think it's going to be
pointing away?
The aways have it.
Democracy wins again, Debby.
It's away in that case.
So you have a little practice to
think about
how such things work.
And they'll be more of these as
we go along here.
So those two methyls will be
trans preserving the kind of
relation they had in the
starting material through that
particular transition state.
Now is that true?
So here we take a methyl--
first we'll look at
regiochemistry, and then we're
going to look at
stereochemistry.
So regiochemistry first. So now
we can imagine this diene,
the methyl substituted diene. To
be either approaching this
way or to be upside down.
It could be either way.
So we're going to slide it over
the top of the other one
like that and make the new
bonds.
And notice in this case, once we
unfold it-- to unfold it,
we're going to have to grab this
bond. It's in the form of
a U. When it makes those new
bonds on the
left, see like that.
One is on top:
one's on the bottom.
They made these new bonds here.
And we're going to have to
unfold it like that to draw a
normal picture of it.
And when we do that this methyl
group is going
to come over here.
That is the new blue double bond
is here on the right, but
when we grab and pull it out to
the left
it's going to be there.
So spacial perception is
entering into the--
is raising its ugly head now.
And in this case when we fold it
out. The methyl is obviously
going to be down.
Now, in fact, those two products
form.
9% of this and 45% of this.
Now why is there's so much more
of this transition state
than of that transition state?
Incidentally, notice that the
diene is not only over this
double bond, it's also as close
as it can be to the CO
double bond.
There's a secondary interaction
of the orbitals
that makes it go that way,
that's called endo
orientation, but don't worry
about that.
I struggled here, how to do
this, to
make it look realistic.
That's the way it really does.
Most people wouldn't draw that
way. They'd draw it
approaching just the diene here,
and the
alkene on the right.
And this would come in, and that
would come in, and they
would draw the new bonds.
But really it approaches above,
and I think that's
interesting.
So that's why I took the trouble
to draw it that way.
But when you do that, you notice
that the diene could be
either such that it's close to
the CO2 or it
could be out here.
So it if you look at it from the
top, it can either be a U
or it could be an S. And it
prefers to be a U to have the
diene closer to the carbonyl.
So given that that's true, why
might you expect to get rather
little of this and more of the
bottom stuff.
Any ideas?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: Is it because they're
approaching the CO group and
the CH3, they're sterically
hindered?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, even though the
diene is attractive to
that group on the bottom which
is why it's formed into a U
rather than an S-- you would
also have it
close in this case,
but in the case on top, you have
those two methyls on top
of one another.
So it looks like steric
hindrance could explain this.
But there's another possibility
as well.
Perhaps, there's an
intermediate.
Perhaps, one bond forms first in
the rate-determining step,
and then a second bond forms,
and you have this intermediate
which on this side is anion
adjacent to a carbonyl group.
So that is an enolate.
And on the left it's allylic
because we can draw our
resonance structure of that.
Now if that were true, if you
had this intermediate, why
might you predict getting more
of this than of this?
More of the stuff on the bottom.
Why is the one of the bottom a
better allylic intermediate?
Mary, do you have any idea?
The only difference between the
allyl on the top and the
allyl on the bottom is where the
methyl is.
In the top, it's on the middle
carbon.
In the bottom, it's on a
terminal
carbon on the double bond.
Let's think about the resonance
structure you would draw.
Mary, were you about to say
something?
STUDENT: Oh, I was going to say
more substituted alkenes--
PROFESSOR: Aha!
In that resonance structure this
methyl is stabilizing
that cation.
Not in this case, when it's on
the middle carbon because the
allylic charges on one end or
the other.
So one could say that this is a
more stable intermediate
and, therefore, you get that.
Or it could just be that the
transition state is a little
unsymmetrical the way we showed
in other cases, where a
bridge thing like mercury wasn't
in the middle but a
little toward one side.
So it could just be that both
bonds form at once, but not
precisely in step with one
another, one a little more
than the other.
If it went through an
intermediate, there's a test
for it to see whether there's an
intermediate.
Because if you have an
intermediate then you would
imagine that it could rotate
here.
So this could move over here
before it formed a new bond.
Or indeed, this one could rotate
around this bond and bring
that, instead of on the top
where it is now, on the bottom
as it approaches this one.
So we could have these rotations
that would change
the stereochemistry of the
product.
So we can test that.
So let's look at the
stereochemistry of the ene.
Now we've put two of these
groups on, and they're cis to
one another.
And if we put that on top, and
make the new bonds, and then
fold it back, grab this new
double bond, the one here and
fold it back, we see that these
two groups will be
adjacent to one another- cis.
So we'd expect a cis product.
When we form
those new red bonds.
So a cis alkene should give a
cis cyclohexene, and that, in
fact, forms in 68% yield.
If you take the other
stereoisomer of the alkene,
the trans one, and do the
same trick you get the trans
cyclohexene, and that one in 84%
yield.
And this is what you actually
isolate and can
sell to your neighbor.
You don't form the wrong isomer.
So it doesn't rotate.
So there's not an intermediate.
So the diene just sits down on
the ene.
It forms the two sigma bonds
simultaneously from the same
face right from the top here.
So there's no rotatable
intermediate with only one new
sigma bond.
So you didn't have this
situation
where you could rotate.
So it's a concerted reaction.
you form both bonds at once.
Now, how about with respect to
the diene stereochemistry?
Here we have E and E, the
trans arrangements around
those two double bonds.
So we put those on top, form the
new bonds, and you see
that now, as drawn here, the
product, in 81% yield, has
everything cis.
This carbon, this carbon, this
carbon, and this carbon.
Now these two carbons in the
ring being cis to one another
are not surprising you couldn't
make those trans that
would be to strained.
But that they are cis to these
says that this had to be in
the U form here, not the S form.
And that these are both up shows
that you formed both
bonds at once as shown here.
And this is another place for
you to sit in your room. And
think about how these things
will unfold. And what points
and what direction.
Now if you take this E-Z
isomer. And do the same trick,
then in 15 hours at a 150
degrees you get this to be
trans, instead of cis.
But notice the difference in
conditions.
This one happens in 5 minutes at
a 120 degrees.
This one takes 15 hours at a
much higher temperature, 30
degrees Celsius hotter.
So there's something wrong,
something is
slow about this reaction.
Now, can we figure out what
might be
slow about that reaction.
Why might it be bad to come in
and do this.
Notice that the hydrogen and the
methyl are near one
another. When we have the
rotation around this single
bond so that these are adjacent
to one another.
So it would prefer the s-trans
conformation.
S means the single bond in
a diene
between two double bonds.
So it could be s-cis or s-trans.
So this prefers to be s-trans,
but to do the Diels-Alder
reaction it has to be cis so
those terminal carbons could
be near the same ene.
So because it prefers to be this
way, it's much harder.
You have to put in extra energy
to make it s-cis, as
well as to do the reaction.
Now just to show you some of the
variety of the Diels-Alder
reaction, it's not just simple
compounds like the ones we
showed here, you can use the
acetylenes.
So we do that trick in this one
at 150
degrees you get a diene--
a cyclohexadiene product.
Because acetylene, when it loses
one of its bonds,
becomes an ene not a single
bond.
Or you can have a ring involved
like this.
And notice that that's the
product, and it happens very
fast at 1M concentration, the
half-life--
or the equivalent of a
is a second at room
temperature--
actually below room temperature.
So have you ever seen a skeleton
like that before?
Let me draw it a little
differently.
Yeah, Rahul?
STUDENT: The Ziegler-Natta,
or umm...
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's two names.
STUDENT: The metathesis with...
PROFESSOR: Right, this is the
starting material when it had
hydrogens there for the
metathesis polymerization--
the ring-opening metathesis.
That's actually absolutely true,
but I was thinking of an
earlier example of it.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Bartlett and Knox?
PROFESSOR: Ah! The Bartlett and
Knox skeleton could
be made that way.
So you can make bicyclic
compounds by
a Diels-Adler reaction.
Or look at this one, this
molecule this unsaturated
aldehyde is called acrolein.
And you can take two molecules
of that, and dimerize them.
What's special about this one?
How's that different from the
other ones?
What's special about the
6-membered ring?
It has an oxygen in it.
It's not just carbons that can
do this trick.
So what they all have in common
is they form a 6-
membered ring with a double bond
in it.
Although, if you use an
acetylene it could be two
double bonds.
But when you want to do a
synthesis project and you see
that there's a 6-membered ring
with a double bond in it,
you think Diels-Alder reaction.
So you see, if you can take it
apart into an ene and a diene
that would do that kind of
thing.
So, the Diels-Alder reaction has
this cyclic, six-electron
transition state, the one we
look at here.
And we could actually look at
what the transition state
looks like and the motion at the
time the two bonds are
being formed in parallel.
So we have the HOMO in front and
the LUMO behind, or
actually on top, and those will
interact to give a HOMO--
not the HOMO, but the HOMO -1 as
it turns out in
the transition state.
But it has this node right down
the middle that both of
the starting pieces had.
And if you look at the LUMO on
the bottom and the HOMO on the
top, then they give the HOMO in
the transition state which
doesn't have the node down the
middle.
So that's how they go together
in the transition state.
And here we see, I think, the
motion that's involved in
going through the transition
state.
It's curious that the hydrogens
stay more or less in
place and the carbons do most of
the moving
in forming the bonds.
Now can we do the same thing
with two alkenes?
Can we take two alkenes and have
them come together to
form a cyclobutane?
What do you think?
Any thoughts on this one?
How many electrons involved in
this ring that we're making in
the transition state when we are
bringing these together
and make them overlap?
How many electrons are changing
in this process?
Ayesha?
STUDENT: Two pi to two sigma
electrons.
PROFESSOR: There is pi here, and
pi here-- that's four
electrons--
and they become these two bonds
here, two sigma bonds.
So, there are four electrons.
So it's 4n, where n is 1, not
4n+2, as in
the Diels-Alder reaction.
So this one would have an
anti-aromatic transition state.
Of course, it also is strained
here, so the reaction might be
expected to go the other way,
but that doesn't work either.
It's the same transition state
with four pi electrons--
four electrons involved.
So it doesn't work in either
direction.
On the other hand, another way
of looking at it is the HOMO
of one is orthogonal to the LUMO
of the other.
That's the same analysis we did
in showing why H2 can't
add to an alkene.
But if we shine light on it then
we take an electron out
of the HOMO and put it into the
LUMO, and now you can get
stabilization because you've
changed the symmetry of what
the orbitals are.
So now in the excited state the
HOMO can interact with the
LUMO of the other one because
you've changed it from pi to
pi-star in putting light in.
So that is when you shift an
electron from the HOMO to the
LUMO, then you can get the
reaction to occur.
And it's an important reaction
for most people. Because this
is a DNA of a double helix.
On the right is A-T-T-G and on
the left is T-A-A-C. But if we
looked right here in the middle,
we see two T's.
So if we zoom in on that we're
looking in the
plane of that thing.
Let's rotate it out toward you
so you look down
on those two T's.
We'll look at just that bit
of it...
and rotate it up... and that's
what it looks like, and we could
see what's in front and
what's in back this way.
And notice there is a double
bond here, and
a double bond here.
Will they react the with one
another to make a cyclobutane?
No, because it's four pi
electrons that are involved.
It's not an aromatic transition
state.
How could you make them react
with one another?
Pardon me.
STUDENT: Light.
PROFESSOR: With light.
So if you use UVB and don't put
on sunscreen, then you get
that reaction happening, and it
forms a cyclobutane.
And this thymine
photodimerization to do that
makes the chain kink... of that
chain where the two dimerized.
And that inhibits DNA
replication and transcription
and is believed to be the main
source of the mutations that
gives rise to melanomas.
So that's why you put your
sunscreen on
that takes out UVB.
It's to stop that
photodimerization of thymine.
Now we've been looking at
cycloadditions... which is one
class of these things where the
pericyclic reactions--
where you can have aromatic
transition states.
And now we're going to look at
the other kind which is
electrocyclic reactions, where
you start with a conjugated
chain and curl it around to make
a ring.
So you can start with hexatriene
and make a new bond
at the bottom, shift the pi
bonds to make a cyclic
compound, cyclohexadiene.
Now, of course, you have groups
that are substituted on
the ends here. Maybe just
hydrogens that are in the
plane in the starting material,
but in and out of
the plane in the product.
So you're going to have to twist
those carbons to make
those things that are in-plane
out-of-plane.
So changing the pi to the sigma
bond requires a twist in
one of two ways.
You can either twist it this
way. Where this comes up and
that goes down, and that's
called conrotation,
because as we look at it here
both of them are going
counterclockwise in the same
direction.
Or we could go through this
other geometry and rotate this
one counterclockwise, but the
one on the left clockwise, and
that's called disrotation, they
rotate in opposite
directions.
Either way would take these four
groups here and make them
in and out of the plane as they
need to be to form a
sigma bond.
Is there a preference between
these?
Well notice... if you do it this
way, that the p orbitals that
are on top in the starting
material are bending in toward
one another.
The top of one end touches the
top of the other end... as they
rotate in opposite directions.
So that among these orbitals,
there's always going to be an
even number of nodes.
This has no nodes, but if you
change the sign here to make
this a node here, you'd have to
have a node
someplace else as well.
So you have to have an even
number of nodes.
We saw that in benzene too.
So that's like these things that
were involved in in the
Hueckel rule where you have a
ring and they all touch one
other on the top.
You have an even number of
nodes.
But if you twist in the opposite
direction then the
top on the right touches the
bottom on the left, and now as
you go around you have an odd
number of nodes.
There's a node here between
these two as they're beginning
to touch, but no other nodes.
So an odd number of nodes.
So it's just the opposite of
what Hueckel is.
Now what name should we
associate with that?
Have you ever seen something
that looks like that?
What's funny about it?
You notice if you trace the top
of it, you get a node
where it has to change from red
to blue, if red is one
sign and blue is the other sign
of a p orbital.
It had to twist so at one place
there's a node as you go
around this if you drew a bunch
of p orbitals on that.
So you have to have an odd
number of nodes if you have
that connectivity.
And I heard you say that that's
called a Moebius strip.
So the opposite of Hueckel is
Moebius--
two different ways of doing this
rotation to form the
sigma bond, Hueckel and Moebius.
Now here's the transition state
that would do the Hueckel
where the top is touching the
top to form a sigma bond.
And notice that as you do that
you
preserve a mirror of symmetry.
On the left there's not a
mirror.
Do you see what symmetry there
is on the left?
What will change the left hand
side of this molecule into the f
right hand side?
What does it look like?
Things like this, it's like a
propeller.
If I could do it, here.
So it has an axis of symmetry
that happens all the way from
the starting material to the
product.
So this has a mirror. And this
has an axis of symmetry.
Now let's see what that does.
Let's follow each orbital in the
starting material as it
becomes an orbital in the
product, and see which
starting material orbital
becomes which product orbital
for these two different ways:
the Hueckel connectivity where
you always have a mirror of
symmetry, and the Moebius where
you always have an axis of
symmetry.
So of these six--
you have six atomic orbitals
here, a p orbital here, here,
here, here, here, here, six.
We have six molecular orbitals,
no nodes, one node,
two nodes, three nodes, four
nodes, five nodes of which
three are occupied by the three
electron pairs.
The same starting material over
on the right, and in the
product, we have four p
orbitals in the conjugated
systems, so psi-1, -2, -3, -4.
No nodes, one node, two nodes,
three nodes but we have a
sigma and a sigma-star in the
product in both cases.
But we have the question of
where do the electrons that
start here end up at the
product.
That's our question... to track
the MOs.
So let's look first at psi-1,
and we'll use as a model the
aromatic analog, Hueckel
connectivity, where we're
not doing this reaction
but just looking at a benzene.
This is what we did last time.
Remember if we bring these two
ends together, they'll touch
here, and that'll become more
stable.
So this one here goes down in
the product.
We looked at that last time.
So that will happen--
here is at the transition state,
and you see that when
you have the mirror that's
happening.
The ones that are red on top are
overlapping here, and it's
going to build as it goes on
toward product.
This will get bigger and bigger
because that's an
important overlap.
The pi-bonds back here get
smaller and smaller, and this
orbital of the starting
material, this one, smoothly
converts into sigma through that
transition state.
So psi-1 becomes sigma.
Now think about it on the left.
As you begin to do it, as you
rotate them in opposite
directions, the bottom here
touches the top here.
That's going toward a sigma*
anti-bond not
toward a bond.
In fact how it avoids going way,
way up in energy--
that electron pair--
is to decrease the size in front
and increase it in back.
But when it increases in back,
it forms psi-1.
It makes the nodeless set of
four here.
So this one doesn't go to sigma
the way it did here, it
goes to psi-1.
Now let's look at-- there are
three pairs of electrons were
talking about, that's the lowest
one of
the starting material.
Let's look at the next one.
As we brought it together to
make a ring in the aromatic
case. That was unfavorable
antibonding.
So, in fact, this pair of
electronics went up in energy,
and if we look here. We see the
same thing.
This psi-2--
where we're starting--
is ending up in a pi orbital.
Notice it's decreasing in front
and increasing and back,
but with a node because of that
mirror.
So it's not psi-1 the lowest--
the one where all the p's are in
phase-- it is the one that
has a node in the middle.
So it goes to psi-2 of the
product.
But over on this side it goes to
sigma because if it had a
node here in the beginning, now
the red on the bottom and
red on the top are touching one
another.
So that's going to make sigma.
Now let's look at the third
electron pair.
And we saw that in the aromatic
system it
went down in energy.
And in this case, here it is at
the transition state, and
it's going down in energy, and
in fact, it's
going to form psi-1.
It's not so easy to see that
here, but you can see that
it's decreasing in front at
least. I admit that
it's hard to see.
On the other side over here it's
going to decrease in
front because that's an
antibonding interaction.
But the thing it's getting in
back is blue, red, and red.
It's got two nodes.
So it's not going to psi-1,
we've already done that, it's
not going to psi-2, which has
only one node, it's going to
psi-3, which has two nodes.
And that is terrible.
Those electrons are--
these sort of cancel one
another, but these are going
way upstairs.
Whereas over here, these two
sort of canceled one another,
but this is going downstairs.
So it's much easier to do the
Hueckel then it is Moebius if
you have three electron pairs.
Notice that if you had only two
electron pairs, you'd have
this which more or less cancels
versus if you had only
two electron pairs this one goes
up more so.
So it goes the other way.
We can also look at what would
happen
with the other orbitals.
And notice that if we took an
electron from here, and put it
into here, then it's going to go
down in energy.
So photochemically, we could
make it prefer the left path
with six electrons.
So, again, that's what actually
happens thermally in
a normal reaction, it's the
Hueckel with six
electrons not Moebius.
So disrotation is preferred for
a six electron shift, so
that if you have methyls like
that, the two methyls will end
up on the same side.
Say if this one rotates up, this
one also rotates up.
That is if it's my little
fingers, they go like that,
they rotate in opposite
directions, not in the same
direction or one would go up and
the other down.
So stereochemistry shows you the
form-- and notice that the cis
is the less stable isomer.
It's not forming that because
it's more stable. It's forming
it despite the fact that it's
less stable, because it
prefers to do that.
That's 4n+2.
So how can you study whether the
opposite conrotation would
occur like this if it were 4n
electrons?
What system would you look at?
How would you get four electrons
rather than six?
What starting material would you
use?
Any ideas?
Here you start with hexatriene
so what do you go to use?
Nathan?
STUDENT: A diene?
PROFESSOR: The diene, butadiene.
So we'll do this, we will start
with butadiene that has
methyls substituted, so we know
stereochemistry.
And we expect it then to do--
if it does--
let's see so we got methyl on
the right here, and on the
left here, and if they do
conrotation, they'll come out
on the same side.
So that's what we'll do, but
there's a problem.
And the problem is this, this
reaction is exothermic by 16
kilocalories because you're
converting a pi bond into a
sigma bond.
But up above it's not so great
because you're forming a
cyclobutane which is strained.
And that is uphill 11
kilocalories per mole.
The reaction won't work.
That's not so great.
So we can't do that reaction,
right?
We can't study it with that
system.
Right?
Wrong.
We can run it the other
direction.
Start with the
dimethocyclobutane and see
which butadiene it forms.
Because it's the same
transition state when you run
one way and the other.
If you have a certain transition
state that's low,
you can access it not only
coming this direction, but
also that same low one coming
back.
So we can do the same test
starting with the cyclic form
and coming back.
And that was done by Brauman and
Archie in 1972, and it's
interesting to see how they made
the compound.
This what they needed that
cis-dimethylcyclobutane.
How did they make it?
They made it starting with a
cycloaddition where acetylene
adds to a double bond to give a
cyclobutene.
And it had these carbons
attached to it which then they
reduced off.
We will talk about that reaction
later.
And they made the OH as a good
leaving group with a tosylate.
And then they used H- to do the
displacement to convert
that into methyl.
But the crucial reaction was
this cycloaddition.
How does that look to you to add
a triple bond to a double
bond to make a four-membered
ring?
Good or bad?
Bad.
It's 4n electrons, two pi bonds
coming together.
But what do you notice?
how do they make it work?
They wanted to do that.
What was special?
STUDENT: They used light.
PROFESSOR: It's a four-electron
cycloaddition that
should be bad, but they used
light to do it.
So they put the electron into
the orbital of opposite
symmetry. And now it will work.
So we already saw that forms the
less stable isomer, so
it's disrotation with six
electrons.
But this is the experiment they
did, at 280 degrees--
it's not an easy reaction--
the ring opened up and they got
this isomer as expected.
So this rotated in to the right,
and this rotated out to
the right, it's conrotation.
Like that.
So it's disrotation with six
electrons, conrotation with
four, and what was special about
them was not only did
they measure that that was
99.9%, they measured how much
of the other one there was.
There was about 0.005%.
This was really, really careful
work they did, and
it's an interesting paper to
read.
So that says--
notice that this is the less
stable isomer. Because it has a
cis bond where these are
both trans.
So there's the bias that
favors--
that 99.9 to 0.005 is 11
kilocalories per mole--
but the bias in favor of this
kind of rotation must be even
higher, because it's being hurt
by the fact that this one
is strained.
So it's something greater than
11 kilocalories per mole
favoring the transition state
for conrotation in that. Which
supports what we predicted by
theory.
And if you have an
eight-membered
ring with four double
bonds in it, that reaction
happens at -10 degrees and
again it rotates like that, it's
a conrotation.
So it's conrotation for 4n
electrons here, or here,
n is 0, n is 1.
But it's disrotation for 4n+2.
So it's what we expected for
these electrocyclic reactions.
And we can look at the
transition states for the two
and see that that's what would
happen if you could run it
forwards, and there's the
transition state.
This is the same kind of thing
we did before.
I'm not going to dwell on this
now.
Now a particular example of that
kind of thing is opening
Dewar benzene.
Remember last semester we talked
about Dewar who sent
Kekule these models of all the
different possible structures
for benzene, and one of them was
this which came to be
called Dewar benzene, even
though he didn't advocate that
as a structure benzene.
He thought it was this, the same
way other people did, but
he said it's a conceivable
structure of benzene.
But notice that this one would
be strained, and that one
would be stable.
So if you could go from this to
this, if you could get
this, it would be way down hill
in energy. Because this is
unusually stable being aromatic.
This is unusually unstable.
Because it has two four
membered rings.
So it would really help to do
that.
So it should be a really easy
reaction.
It really wants to open up.
Now does it?
Well in 2004, there was a paper
where they calculated
the energy for isomers of
benzene, and they had all
these isomers of benzene,
there's benzene, and there
were 218 isomers.
And, in fact, 84 of them are
calculated to be within 100
kilocalories, benzene is the
lowest one, but there are many
within the strength of a bond
above it.
And, in fact, six of them have
been prepared, but they don't
go to benzene because breaking a
single bond--
these are more than 100
kilocalories above.
So if you could go to benzene by
breaking a bond it would be
very favorable, but you can't
because if you look at these
structures breaking a single
bond won't take you to
benzene, you have to break more
bonds than that.
However, Dewar benzene, which is
this one here, is 74
kilocalories above benzene, and
you only have to break one
bond to make a change into
benzene.
But it lasts for two days at
room temperature.
Why doesn't it go way downhill?
How was it prepared?
It was prepared by van Tamelen
and Pappas in 1963.
And they did it, you notice by
an electrocyclic reaction
where they take a diene and make
it into a cyclobutene.
And it had disrotation so they
used light to do it again,
another example.
But it has a half-life of two
days at room temperature
whereas this one, which is only
11 kilocalories
exothermic. Remember that was
the one that had to be heated
to 280 degrees in order to go,
so that one has a barrier of 33
kilocalories per mole. But
this one only 25,
not what you would expect on the
simple analysis.
So it's 66 kilocalories more
exothermic, but only 8
kilocalories per mole faster.
It is faster, but not very much
faster.
So this one, notice, opens
conrotatory.
We talked about that, that's
what Brauman showed, and
that's what you expect for 4n
electrons where n is 2 to make
the two double bonds.
But in this case-- and the HOMOs
and LUMOs there, but in
this case if you want to open it
up to make benzene. This has
to go that way, and that has to
go that
way to become planer.
If one of them went the other
direction, you'd have really
weird bond angles.
Benzene would look like this
instead of being a hexagone,
it would look like this if you
rotated the wrong way.
So you have to rotate it in the
wrong way to do that.
But wait a second, how many
electrons here?
There's going to be one on that
p orbital, one there, one
here, one here, one here, that's
six.
Six pi electrons is supposed to
be disrotation.
Shouldn't that work?
No.
It looks like there's something
more fundamental.
It's more fundamental that when
you're breaking this bond
here and making sigma*, it
doesn't overlap with the HOMOs
here and here to stabilize.
So even though it's the right
number of electrons the HOMOs
and LUMOs aren't lining up
right.
So it's not numerology we're
fundamentally interested in,
it's whether HOMOs and LUMOs
matched to get stability.
The next topic is going to be
spectroscopy, and we'll get to
that next Wednesday after the
exam on Monday.